did Madonna really make Weird Al
Yankovic parody her music and did he
really compose his first songs in the
bathroom here's what the bizarre sort of
biopic weird the Al Yankovic story
actually manages to get right
hope you guys are ready for this
[Applause]
Mel's parents Nick and Mary Yankovic are
depicted as harsh and authoritarian and
weird the out Yankovic story The
portrayal is greatly exaggerated for
Comic effect but there is some truth to
their strictness according to the San
Luis Obispo Tribune Al's religious
upbringing caused him to abstain from
drugs alcohol and even swearing Mary
controlled her son in other ways too the
young owl short for Alfred was not
allowed to visit friends homes or have
sleepovers and he was only permitted to
ride his bike to his aunt's house just
half a block away even then Mary would
watch from the front lawn embodying the
term helicopter parents some 20 years
before it entered common parlance
however despite her best efforts Mary
could not come between Al and his
favorite disc jockey Dr Demento whom she
considered inappropriate to avoid her
earshot Al lowered his radio's volume
and took it under the bed sheets
the film depicts a door-to-door Salesman
visiting the Yankovic home and
introducing the young owl to guitars and
accordions this is true according to the
New York Times magazine although it was
not Al's choice of instrument in real
life that decision was made by his
mother Mary who chose the accordion
because Frankie Yankovic no relation was
America's reigning poker King guitars
may have been cooler but Al really took
to his accordion the first lesson was on
October 22nd 1966 the day before Al's
seventh birthday and his teacher showed
him the difference between beginner
intermediate and adult-sized accordions
with so much time spent at home Al made
quick progress with his accordion and by
early adolescence he was able to play
along to some of his favorite albums
else accordion also helped him overcome
his shyness Al would perform in the dorm
room at his roommate's behest breaking
awkward barriers in the process
anyone got an accordion
Al's conception of My Bologna is one of
the film's funniest sequences the curly
Maestro is making sandwiches for his
housemates when inspiration strikes as
the Knacks My Sharona plays on the radio
Al's eyes meet with a pack of bologna
and as if through divine intervention
the DJ's record appears to stick and
repeats the chorus several times
Yankovic's inspiration gets stronger
with every repetition and before his
friends have time to change the station
Al rushes to his accordion to give the
first performance of My Bologna
enthralled Al and his bandmates rushed
to make a recording and they choose a
bus station toilet because of the
favorable Acoustics this is true
although it wasn't at a bus station Al
actually made the recording in a men's
bathroom at California Polytechnic State
University Yankovic likely got some
strange looks but the unorthodoxy was
worth it My Bologna did so well on the
Dr Demento show that it reached the
Knack song by Sharona had inspired Al's
goofy cover sometime later Yankovic met
with the band during a show at Cal Poly
lead vocalist Doug Fieger received Al
warmly praising his cover is a really
great song and Advising Ruby Perry the
then Vice President of Capitol Records
to get Yankovic on board it was at this
moment that Weird Al believed he had a
shot in the business
the film sees Weird Al Perform his first
show in a rough Punk joint full of
heckling thugs after an unpromising
start Al hits his stride and The Crowd
Goes Wild this scene is a mix-up as far
as accuracy is concerned Hal did stir
crowds early in his career but the first
instance occurred on campus at Cal Poly
not a boozy Dive Bar it was an open mic
night sometime in 1977 after his
counter-cultural peers did their thing
Al took to the stage with his friend Joe
Miller and played an Eclectic 10-minute
medley That was supposed to be a cover
of every song in history the crowd loved
it there were cheers Applause and a
standing ovation it was the first time
that Yankovic had ever had such positive
reinforcement according to an interview
in the New York Times magazine
consequently with the help of an LA
manager Al landed a show that bore
greater resemblance to the dive we see
in the film The Venue was a large
nightclub in Phoenix and like a Cal Poly
the audience loved him however it wasn't
all plain sailing When Alan is banned
open for missing persons at the Santa
Monica Civic Auditorium they endured 45
minutes of abuse instead of laws there
were cries of get off the stage and you
suck
with his top hats and eccentric demeanor
Dr Demento May strike the unfamiliar
viewer as another figment of Yankovic's
Lively imagination but Demento was a
real individual and he really did
discover Yankovic he didn't meet
Yankovic at a live event though but on
the airwaves in 1976 Yankovic sentimento
a recording of Belvedere cruising a song
he wrote about his family's rickety old
car Demento accepted it playing the
jingle on air Yankovic followed this up
with numerous other mixtapes namely the
aforementioned My Bologna which was a
hit on demento's show and then with
listeners Nationwide that that became
viral in the days before things went
viral and weird the Al Yankovic story
Madonna is depicted as a musician of
secondary status who latches on to
Yankovic to further her own career the
inverse is true but it's all part of the
film's rise and fall farce there's no
proof that Madonna and Weird Al have
even met it's obvious that there's
something going on with me and Madonna
So everybody was like did that really
happen however there is a sliver of
Truth in how the film shows Madonna
inquiring about a Weird Al cover of her
song virgin in an interview with
soundcheck Yankovic said Madonna was
actually the person who suggested that I
do the parody Like a Surgeon apparently
Madonna was walking with a friend when
she mentioned Weird Al suggesting that
his cover could be like a surgeon
fortunately this brand new Al's manager
Yankovic has made a point of conceiving
his own cover lyrics but Madonna's rhyme
was just too good the parody single was
released in the summer of 1985 reached
number 47 on the Billboard 100 and
became one of Yankovic's most enduring
songs
[Music]